this so your doctor emailed and said hey
I hope you've stuck to a good fitness
regimen and diet right you don't want to
talk about it well I'm gonna talk about
it be brother up bring it up babe so we
could talk so like so I clean out your
car over the weekend and I find I
accidentally sit on a second
melted Snickers bar happy from the same
from the same Snickers bar by the way
yeah and I found a different
butterfingers - I love butterfingers
they're still crispy in the middle so
what is a commercial so crispy in the
middle of butter because they're the
great greatest it's a flaky you know the
layers of flakes yeah I'll give you that
what I'm seeing is where do we go from
here
because we are determined that you were
pre-diabetic okay so where do we go I'm
gonna ask you a question now you're
gonna go full dire
can I go can I go BT's you want to go
full beating yeah yeah I'll go for
biddies yeah is that what you're going
for
I'm gonna look at you right now yeah
okay friend okay okay girlfriend yes
girl good I mean okay all right so I'm
in Schaumburg Illinois okay okay right
by a mega mall okay what's around there
is TGI Fridays yeah okay Olive Garden
these are the restaurants are on there
yeah very suburb II suburb yeah right
and I have no car and it's cold as [ __ ]
okay
and I wake up during the day and I go
I'm hungry okay where do I go not eat
no you're butterfingers - and Snickers
bar I found in the car not a vegetarian
I'm just telling you what I did last
weekend there are healthy options even
in the shittiest of places you just have
to know what you want Brown lettuce why
was everybody has a brown lettuce yes I
want you to eat rotten lettuce Oh Kyle I
equal you don't like it you cold out
what do you call it
okaaaaay okaaaaay okaaaaay who can i
babe I'm trying to survive out there
babe well you're not gonna survive much
longer if you can't I'm gonna try a
Butterfinger diet it's flaky you know in
the middle right when you've been do it
it's hard for me I have another what is
your
favorite candy bar really quick Oh
anything with coconut I think so Almond
Joy it used to be the cheap stuff I'm
enjoy but I like I gotta eat anything
Gilbert and I went on a Fat Boy spree so
I can't even like I can't even hound you
that badly because all Gilbert and I did
all weekend
yeah was eat bad things and you know
he's I've never just seen him
Gilbert it is a true Fat Boy in the
sense that he never eats in front of
people he that he hides he has stashes
or he he'll he'll eat with us right eat
a small amount and he'll say bye bye bye
guys and then wait five minutes in the
parking lot and go back in the
restaurant so he can order himself like
a bigger pot so he can he doesn't need
the judge he doesn't get the judgements
from us I didn't know him I didn't know
fat birth until this weekend
I never seen anybody look at green tea
pancakes with mascarpone quite like
Gilbert did are they good
he is the most efficient garbage
disposal slash vacuum that I have ever
encountered in my life and we were
really bad this weekend is that true
yeah are you crying are you crying right
now
why are you crying crying to cats but
yeah I you you feel like you're gonna
get fat again I'm gonna get fat again I
she's bringing all these memories and
he's Oh hide hold chickens under his bed
why don't tell people that
oh my pretty sure is not a surprise
until I see this used to hoard food then
huh yeah and you only underneath the bed
you had Legos stashes I used to have
boxes of just like candy bars like the
movie fat camp yeah yeah
what's wrong with that though maybe
we're just born to be a fat guy no no I
would not go back to that cuz I never
got laid do you get laid now yes okay
that's a win that's what I'm saying if I
get fat again I will lose confidence I
won't get laid yeah
that it's just you wanna set the system
dry when we have to pay for your
diabetic foot ulcer I'm sorry but look I
was on board not all athletes I haven't
worked out at [ __ ] day in two years
look I'm saying I was I ate just as bad
as you this weekend
are you [ __ ] tears about like what
you regret recently because you're
eating these pancakes all right or you
or are you like literally going back in
the past crying cuz even is reliving it
you missed the food want some hot dogs
right ears are a couple things one I
missed the food like dis reminded me
like her just be like eat this eat this
I was like he didn't say no to one thing
I didn't say no to anything and then
what you do after lab cuz you seem to
look great and look I'll look at this
right here sweetie yeah okay so these
are two empty packs of top so good so
good chocolate dipped mangos yeah and
there were three packs of regular dried
mangoes and I put them here so that
George and all of us could share today
podcast he ate all of this in half a day
and then when I went out and I how do
you something right now those were gifts
to me those are his favorite I get to
[ __ ] do ten of these boxes well yeah
God about being I don't care I'd eat wax
oh my god alright I can't believe I
weighed that much weight before you want
Gilbert I won't let you get fat again
it's a good thing I don't feel pain
we're right here
no maybe lick it against really lick it
yep [ __ ] you close for Hana don't
setting that's awesome sick [ __ ] Bobbi
hey okay now I get to do with you since
you ate a deep dish Pedro that's [ __ ]
up
I deserve it make sure we zoom up on
Bobby's eyes
oh wow [ __ ] ow why you doing it so hard
it's all about hitting the same spot
don't deviate from steams but how it
makes it painful for oh you don't feel
pain
that's crazy salt fat that's why you
have diabetes
yes because nerves are all dead you know
I get to do you I don't feel pain either
- let me do you got to do you for
cheating on you ain't get [ __ ] up
fatty fat which which part I don't want
it to hurt you baby why don't you love
that she loves me
how's your arm pretty good it's bleeding
but yeah yeah yeah good job guys so
that's the conversation is that one
thing
[Music]